comprendre comment les aimants un abîme
de rothschild qu'on vous fasse une
interview alerte aux roses en à bush
pendant l'été
en un cauchemar pendant les ting le lieu
idéal pour faire l'amour en on va tous
les lieux sans possible d'avoir un peu
d'imagination rôle c'est plutôt oui
plutôt que le métro connaît le mot
incroyable
jason a un beau chercher la sécurité ou
la performance la sécurité
est-ce que vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour
j'ai besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
oui préfère un homme qui fait bien
l'amour mais qu'un fidèle ou un homme
qui fait mal la môme et que les fidèles
un homme qui fait bien l'amour et qui
est un fidèle
vous préféreriez qu'un homme vous quitte
pour une femme ou pour un homme je pense
que là je serais très surprise
effectivement si c'était pour un homme
mais fuit pas non ça vous gênerait plus
que ce soit pour ça mais je n'ai pas
dans le flanc non mais si vous aviez un
homme qui vous trompe avec un homme vous
auriez autant de compréhension que
c'était une femme si je ne peut pas
diriger je laisse faire
ouais voilà vous préférez un homme qui
couche avec une autre en pensant à vous
un homme qui couche avec vous en pensant
une autre c'est ce qu'on appelle quand
même si vous voulez quand un homme vous
dis je ne vous ai jamais trompé ma femme
alors je dis moi je vois pas la
différence entre un monsieur qui va de
5h à 7h avec une dame et revient à la
maison avec un grand sourire de bonne
humeur cas monsieur qui le soir
las le même temps avec sa femme et qui
pense à la voisine voit pas différent
oui alors vous préférez finalement dû
coucher avec une autre en pensant avons
exactement elles s'ouvraient que dans le
couple pose même pas la question dans le
couple il faut tous diront rien savoir
vous pensez qu'il faut rien savoir à
9,11 à savoir est-ce que vous pensez que
embrasser s'est trompé non non on peut
embrasser une femme ou un homme sans
tromper est-ce que sucer c'est tromper
je ne vais pas vous répondre
voilà
[Musique]
la junior aussi l'âme
la peur de feux
[Musique]
je peins pas dans le junior
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien est ce que vous préférez draguer
vous faire draguer dans la guerre
beaucoup préféré larguer ou faire
larguer assad argué on vous avait pas
largué est un sentimental vous préférez
embrassez vous faire embrasser un
brassin caresser ou faire caresser de
quel est le lieu idéal pour faire
l'amour sur un court de tennis sur le
central où l'endroit idéal pour une
frégate dans une auto ouais bah oui
parce que pour vous une frégate c'est
une automobile de chez renault des
années 60
pour christine c voilà c'est ça qui est
drôle mais c'est bien mais aussi ici la
transphobie de la frégate transfuge
absolument si vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour c'est dur ça préférez quoi
se pose pas de questions il faut venir
si tu peux pas de alors oui est ce que
vous préférez une femme qui baissent
bien mais qui est infidèle ou une femme
qui devait mal vécu les fidèles bon une
qui menace bien voilà même si elle est
un fidèle
oui vous pensez qu'elle va rester fidèle
de poisson ah oui c'est sage et vous
christophe je pense pas jouer la ronde
finale mais mon jeu pour ce que tu t'en
fous alors vous préférez qu'elle vous
quitte enfin vous préféreriez qu'elle
vous quitte pour un homme pour une femme
dont le nom est sous préféré être
caressé par quelqu'un qui vous répugne
on va trouver ça
ou bien tu vas pas d'evian qui vous
aiment battu peu quelqu'un quand même
vous préférez que votre femme votre
fiancée couche avec un autre en pensant
à vous vous couchez avec vous en pensant
à un autre ça fait mal ça et ça fait 2 1
ni lui ni notes évoquées une autre en
pensant à moi ouais c'est mieux moi
aussi je trouverais ça qu'est ce qu'il
va faire qu'est-ce que vous prêt que
dans un couple il faut tout se dire ou
rien savoir
cette question étudie tout est dans la
merde c'est sûr n'avait jamais c'est pas
n'avoue jamais christophe vous jamais
n'avez vous jamais demandé est ce
l'effet tatouage sur l'épaule
tous peuvent y voyez pas ça comme devise
il ya la marque haussier qui l'apprécié
est ce que pour vous embrasser s'est
trompé non j'aime bien brasser c'est le
premier séjour ou chez kalanga non je
sais pas ça c'est rendre unis ont fait
pas ça allait quand on m'aide à l'envi à
tromper ou non c'est dur mais c'est dur
on fait pas fait que sam en allemagne
roumanie a pas la langue bassin
quantifie c'est sur les gens
après tu dis la langue mais non ça me
choque
tu te veux ma ds t'embrasser s'est
trompé non même avec la langue
c'est une négociation
ça dépend de la moc acteurs là on arrive
à la question importante dit question
michel rocard et je me suis fait
épingler par laure adler com a connu
beaucoup moins puritaine une certaine
époque au sujet de cette question
laure adler elle a dit que thierry
ardisson demandé cette question là et
que c'est la choqué on l'a connu moins
choqué laure adler bien alors regardez
moi bien l'y nastase est ce que sucer
c'est tromper je sais pas je ne parle
pas bien français
alors
en fait c'est le mot tromper qu'il a pas
grand prix ne bougent pas pendant le
qinghai le bouge pas pendant le génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle est votre première pensée lorsque
vous vous retrouvez face à une femme
séduisante
c'est une belle et séduisante ouais
ouais c'est l'assiduité c'est vraiment s
quand même adriana lit depuis que j'ai
rencontré christian je ne pense plus à
rien lorsque je me trouve en face d'un
homme séduisant
vous y croyez pas je pense être alors on
va continuer le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte pour vous vraiment cacher loin
de mouvement après elle répond pas à
elle dit le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
c'est partout si je suis avec la bonne
personne
non mais c'est intéressant de voir que
bon il y avait une ouverture
l'endroit qui sont l'endroit où vous
seriez incapable de faire l'amour fou
parce que vous pensez l'amour c'est
simplement faire le coït mais moins
l'amour c'est aussi dans le regard donc
faire partout oui c'est vrai nous on a
un peu ici et les français on est comme
des sauvages j'ai répondu dans l'espace
elle a dit dans l'espace je pourrais pas
faire l'amour dans l'espace parce que
j'aurais peur je vous l'accordé à venir
alors est ce que vous préférez draguer
ou vous faire draguer plie de mes deux
elle sait se faire draguer est ce que
vous préférez largué ou vous faire
larguer mais sans larguer en moi j ai
rien à f d'accord elles disent préférer
celle qui lie celle qui part est ce que
vous préférez embrasser ou vous faire
embrasser embrasser elle aussi est sous
préfet rey caresser ou vous faire
caresser
j'aime bien ce qui encore des fantasmes
que vous n'avez pas réalisé
si j'en ai oui j'en ai pas réalisé non
elle vit beaucoup vous y coller quand
même question par été arrêtées jusqu'à
leur répond il faut arrêter de regarder
la télé si vous deviez choisir la moitié
d'une femme ou pendriez le haut ou le
bas la moitié d'une femme ont prié le
haut ou le bas
5 rue le haut le bas
mais la femme ne disent pas anti alors 2
et le client idéal pour une interview
alerte aux roses bien sûr on avoue on
jean galle bien encore les emails la
tire l ena un bon chien et un chat mort
alors doc gynéco vous préférez draguer
ou vous faire draguer draghi largué vous
faire larguer me faire la rue
embrassez vous faire embrasser ça je le
fais vraiment c'est réservé à une élite
de filles moi ça me brise le coeur dont
il ya eu 8 900 filles qui ont droit vous
préférez caresser ou faire caresser
caris & moi aussi
quel est le lieu idéal pour faire
l'amour at on appris d'autres je pensais
que vous préférez défoncer au fun c'est
fini c'est fini pour cela ce parti-là
d'interviewer le lieu idéal pour faire
l'amour oui un porche sous un porche
chose importe le lieu où vous ne pouvez
pas faire l'amour dans une branche
oui est-ce que vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour
j'ai besoin d'aimer pour faire un amour
enfin j'ai besoin
55 en mai 75 pieds quelque chose 60 40
60 pour le second 31 44 pour l'amour
d'accord préférez une femme qui baisent
bien mec est infidèle ou une femme qui
baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
les questions étaient les sujets du bac
là ils vont tenue au bac dans certaines
zones
ouais je vais prendre la fidl la fidl
qui baisent mal elle aimera ça sûrement
à yanbu d'après changer d'avis oui une
gonzesse vous préférez qu'elle vous
quitte pour un mec pour une fille pour
une fille ensuite je pourrai me faire
est-ce que j'ai caressé par quelqu'un
qui vous répugne ou battu par quelqu'un
qui vous aime
oui le sado maso vrai pourquoi pas je
suis pour le sexe et enfin et toutes ses
diversités vous préférez une fille qui
couche avec un autre en pensant à vous
ou qui couche avec vous en pensant à un
autre je préfère une fille qui me
demandent de l'appeler [ __ ] [ __ ]
ouais ben ali et tous qu'elle pense à un
autre enfin dans la vie j'appelle pas de
tous les jours j'appelle pas les filles
puis tu es seul tu met au lit
oui même le demande souvent ces
professionnels moi c'est un assassin
gynécologique
tu crois que tous les jeunes et qu ils
appellent leur passion comme ça
pas été bien renseignés concrètement
c'est lui qui l'a fait vous préférez
vous pouvoir faire tout ce que vous
voulez avec une fille moche ou juste
embrassés sur la bouche une fille
sublime
moi je préfère la moche est ce que pour
vous embrasser s'est trompé ouais c'est
grave si votre 9 embrasser un autre mac
vous considérer qu'elle vous trompe avec
le recul vrai ça peut faire mal
doc gynéco est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper si elle l'a bien fait enfin
comme l'art et nico seube
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
- les clients d'orange de moins en moins
de dentiste c'est lamentable
c'est facile de remplir les gymnases en
même temps bien evelyne est ce que vous
pouvez vous faire draguer ou draguer tag
bleu est ce que vous préférez embrasser
ou vous faire embrasser
2 quel est le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte
les veaux michel je suis tranquille
c'est tombé sur wii le lien bien un dc10
le médiateur marchande
et quand on veut sortir des clés de
ministres à barret vous avez vos secrets
quel est l'endroit où vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour au milieu des
gens donc pas de clubs échangistes
évidemment je suis désolé tirer est-ce
que vous avez c'est très important ça
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer et j'ai besoin d'aimer pour faire
l'amour
est ce que vous préférez un homme qui
fait bien l'amour mais qu'un infidèle ou
un homme qui fait mal d'amour mais qui
est fidèle
si je peux avoir les deux d'accord vous
faites forte de lui apprendre ce que
vous préférez qu'ils couchent avec une
autre en pensant à vous qui couche avec
vous en pensant à une autre ah les
bonnes réponses
je préfère
ah c'est sa réponse
j'ai peur qu'il faut jamais qu'une avec
une autre en pensant à moi mais est-ce
que vous conservez un fantasme non
réalisés bien sûr ça demanderait pas
c'est pas mon genre
non est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
tout faire quand on même nom a brassé
sexuellement
mouais oui
interview à leurs torts aux on ne couche
pas par le parlement ne bouge pas
pendant le singer le gauche pendant le
génial
alors je m'attends à tout mais non c'est
pas ça c'est que l'inter dû alerter rose
on me reproche de la faire cas des
filles tout ça donc j'ai dit le prochain
beau garçon carrie dans l'émission j'ai
fait l'interview alerte orange moi je
vais partir de piturca même fait
insulter je dis rien que je suis
physiquement je suis comment lolita et
bah ouais taya terrible alors interview
à alerter rosa leroux ça c'était ça
excite le redit oui
finalement ce manteau rouge au début
tout le monde s'est foutu de sa gueule
au début de l'émission
finalement ça peut aider peut-être servi
ça peut rendre sans sait jamais canet
vous êtes concentré un pas trop mais je
veux c est ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec 1000 femmes toujours de la
même façon
ou toujours avec la même femme de mille
façons différentes
enfin une façon différente
elles étaient déjà venus non puisque
toujours la même position avec milan
chauffe des crampes
ouais d'accord et vous jamel c'est
pareil bon appareil bien évidemment
ouais ouais la même femme de mille
façons différentes lois telles 1500
façon différente parce qu'on a je
connais plein de technique les 529 de
l'épargné dite plein de bons alors
nettoyer voilà quoi ces deux interviews
vertes et roses
est-ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec une femme munie d'un sexe
d'homme ou avec un homme muni d'un sexe
de femme a cédé nouvelle question est ce
encore pire qu'avant à une femme est
lent qu'une seule kevin
voilà un strict toujours intéressé
et thierry qui cherche à me caser oui
j'aime bien regarder comment c'est le
regardais pas gratter du rose si votre
partenaire vous propose de faire l'amour
à trois vous préféreriez un homme ou une
femme une femme une femme pourquoi je
réfléchis alors dites moi ça c'est très
important et astrid est très attentive
vous préférez faire l'amour ou baiser
nanterre l'amour parce qu'on peut faire
l'amour et ça se transforme en baisse
d'accord avec baiser oui ça c'est des
cdc
c'est incroyable ce que tu réussis à
l'arrêt et répondent ces gens n'ont
maintenant moi je préconise le général
qu'est ce que j'aime bien c'est que
combien de béziers quoi c'est ça
mais cessons de nous mais c'est pas du
tout la porte pas des questions à poser
des questions super important jamais
entré chez lotus est important dans la
vie et c'est super important sur rigoles
ou quoi
c'est la vie ça tient justement voilà
une autre c'est la vraie vie ça vous
préféreriez que votre campagne vous
quitte pour un homme pour les femmes
pour une femme ce que je pense qu'elle
va se lasser un moment et en inde à caïn
alors vous préférez regarder votre
campagne faire l'amour avec un autre ou
faire l'amour avec une autre dans lequel
vous regarde avec une autre pendant
qu'il me rien vous préféreriez coucher
avec une fille kampf la blue une fille
confiante en faisant décaler vrillé pour
n'a pas elle qui tache laser rendement
méfie toi parce qu'en ce moment les
komets lévrier afghan c'est parce qu'il
arrive
quoi qu'il arrive d'accord vous préférez
une femme comprend sans la comprendre où
une femme qu'on compense la demande
[ __ ] tu dis que c'est des conneries
mais que sinon mais la catégorie c puis
des conneries c'est des prises de tête
une femme comprend sans la comprendre ou
qu'on comprend sans la prendre
on comprend sans la comprendre
biden 2,8
guillaume canet
j'ai entendu
avec andré dussollier
[Musique]
vous ne serez pas étonné que nous
fassions une interview alerte aux roses
dans la bouche pendant le thing
cauchemar pendant l'été
bien est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer
pour faire l'amour de faire l'amour pour
aimer ni l'un ni l'autre ne donne quoi
alors la fontasse quel est pour vous le
lieu idéal pour une étreinte la rue la
rue des trottoirs c'est un bordel un
porche nous la rue est ce que vous
préférez un homme qui dès ce bien mais
qui est infidèle ou un homme qui baisent
mal mais qui est fidèle
moi je pense que je préfère un mec qui
bosse bien et qui est fidèle
on n'a pas entamé mais il ya des mecs
qui baisent mal et qui sont fidèles
aussi
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous préférez être caressé
par quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu
par quelqu'un qui vous aime
enfin j'ai dit que j'étais une baleine
échouée kivu rennes crise en soirée est
ce que vous préférez que votre mec fasse
l'amour avec une autre en pensant à vous
ou fast allemand avec vous en pensant à
une autre en pensant une autre ouais
ouais c'est plus sympa clementé rien
aucun ne sont rien de sens que ça arrive
ça c'est comme ça ça peut arriver où
j'ai pas dis merde
non plus à ce moment j'ai pas de max est
ce que vous préférez faire l'amour avec
1000 mec toujours de la même façon
ou avec un mec de mille façons
différentes fraudes mille mec alors la
rose il en avait c'est important la cdéc
et swing mec mais posé les mines mec
toujours la même façon plutôt qu'un mec
de mille façons un référent mi-mai qu un
big mac harb aux profs une vague
l'ariège s'est il pas partie à l'affairé
au clair
sa part de banquiers n'en sait pas où et
bien sûr moi c'est important est ce que
vous dites là parce que moi après j'ai
mes emails toucher les classes
m messieurs
bien que vous soyez avec une amie vu la
tête que vous avez deux façons je suis
sûr c'est un coca en tous les cas vous
n'échapperez pas à l'interview 1er toros
en à bouche
[Applaudissements]
bien arnaud clément est ce que vous
l'avez déjà fait dans l'eau ouais mais
c'est vachement gênant non mais il ya
mes parents mes grands-parents qui
regardent et ou non pasteur l'âge que
vous avez quand même
j'y mets donc le med à kenner avec
est-ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec 1000 femmes toujours de la
même façon
ou avec une femme de mille façons
différentes
deuxième réponse ah oui est-ce que vous
avez besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
ou de faire l'amour pourrait mais j'ai
besoin d'ennemis pour faire un mois est
ce que vous préférez une femme qui
baissent bien mais qui est infidèle ou
une femme quitte buzz mal mais qui est
fidèle
je sais pas j'ai la chance d'avoir les
deux noms que je veux dire les 2 c
l'épidémie de votre problème donc voilà
j'ai pas de problème bien c'est pas bien
j'en ai deux est-ce que vous préféreriez
qu'elle couche avec vous en pensant à un
autre ou qu'elle couche avec un autre en
pensant à vous qu'on fasse l'amour
ensemble et qu'elle pense à un autre ah
ouais le fermier ça quand même
vous êtes sûr de sa sport mon
questionnaire moi j'ai eu un truc
si elle vous propose une partie à trois
préfériez que ce soit avec un homme ou
une femme
ah oui pas [ __ ] du coup il était
fascinant c'est les bonbons dit caresser
par quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu
par quelqu'un qui vous aime c'est les
questionnaires c'est vous qui les fait
virer battue alors maquis battu par
quelqu'un qui vous adresse email et une
batterie doucement ils vous aiment
grosjean c'est la vie dure vous allez
voir pourquoi des dieux est ce que pour
vous sucer c'est tromper
oui ah ouais ouais
ah non mais c'est une question à sens
inverse non ça dépend avec qui
c'est grotesque voilà la réponse
je suis pas certain du charnois j'ai
entendu joker talent j'utilise mon joker
tombe quand on prend un joker ça tombe
sur la personne qui était à côté de vous
dans que bah oui est ce que pour vous
sucer c'est tromper
oui bon voilà encore plus dur et ce
qu'aimer c'est ce qu'il ya de plus beau
j'adore les films où il ya les histoires
d'amour a l'impression que ça arrive
jamais dans la vie mais maintenant je
commence à comprendre en fait que je
sais pas si quelqu'un a eu l'idée c'est
que forcément ça existe quelque part
donc ça ça cette idée là j'adore quoi
c'est du grand art
comme tout va bien avec chrysler on va
faire une interview aux alertes aux
roses
[Applaudissements]
le tabac fisto moi non est-ce que vous
avez besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
ou de faire l'amour pour aimer des mets
pour faire l'amour j'ai jamais fait
l'amour sans aimer une période non paris
un jour d'aujourd'hui faut les mettre à
l'abri
vous préférez une femme qui baisent bien
mais qu'un infidèle ou une femme qui
baisent mal mais qui est fidèle fidélité
avant tout même si elle baisse man magie
j'ai pas vraiment le choix
je choisis la fidélité la fidélité est
plus importante que le plaisir
personnellement oui je veux me sentir en
confiance avec une personne c'est je
voyage beaucoup donc elle donne à sentir
très fidèles parmi vous les emmenez avec
vous maintenant tu as toujours un pas
toujours d'accord
est ce que vous préférez faire l'amour
avec 1000 femmes toujours de la même
manière
ou toujours avec la même femme de mille
manières différentes
toujours avec la même de mille manières
différentes
balles neuves trouver un est-ce que vous
préféreriez que fils leur couche avec un
autre en pensant à vous ou couche avec
vous en pensant à un autre
j'adore avoir des choses à ses pairs est
ce que vous auriez c'est un sportif
annoncé qu'il a
est-ce que vous préféreriez que chris
lord couche avec un autre en pensant à
vous ou avec vous en pensant à un autre
du choix choisi coucher avec moi en
pensant à l'autre pense que tu devrais
qu'elle pense à qui alors pioline
l'homme alors est ce que vous préférez
une femme comprend sans la comprendre ou
qu'on comprend sans la prendre
l'ès 20 minutes je crois que les femmes
on les comprend jamais complètement
si chrysler vous propose un soir une
partie à trois vous préférez que le
troisième ça soit un homme ou une femme
je n'hésite pas longtemps une femme une
femme et elle
j'ose espérer que c'est une femme aussi
alors il a épousé une [ __ ] qui baisse
il a amené les fidèles
elle est vide est ce que vous l'avez
déjà fait dans l'eau oui ah ouais tu
joues a écrit cela elle non est-ce que
vous pensez que rien n'est salle quand
même dans l'eau à partir du moment où
les deux sont d'accord mais là vous êtes
3,6 à retourner à dallas en plus nous en
sortons pas de dans les sondages a pu
virer au campus grand lille on l'offre
initiale non mais je pense à son dos de
fixer les limites et à partir du moment
où l'on sait que quand on aime tout est
possible quoi tout à fait un as dernière
question à la puissance et la terre
fabrice santoro est ce que sucer c'est
tromper
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
interview alerte aux roses franck dubosc
m bonjour madame il dit ça parce que
sabrina pas loin là il valide
franck quel est le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte total 1 dans ma loge après
l'émission d'accord non je ne sais pas
moi je le mondial ce serait entre deux
voitures mal garées
mais avec une contractuelle oui d'accord
quel est l'endroit où vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour franck entre
deux voitures mal garées avec une
contractuelle ja il ya là en public un
public non non je suis très pudique
vous n'êtes pas boîte changé du tout du
tout c'est décidément votre question
tirée enfin c'est non non non non non je
suis désolé
non non c'est pour ça que j'en sors peu
ensemble c'est vrai dès qu'il a un peu
chaud et les filles des gens qui bougent
peu est ce que vous préférez vous pouvez
faire et draguer ou vous faire draguer
me faire draguer ah ouais ouais ouais
par habitude oui c'est plus l'habitude
qui vous fait dire ça que qu'autres
choses nous les garçons est ce que vous
préférez largué ou faire larguer moi je
suis un garçon je suis donc un peu lâche
donc je préfère me faire larguer les
filles ont fait peu ou vous préféré
embrasser ou faire embrasser
quand vous dites satirique j'ai déjà
entendu cette question que vous faites
c'est vous vous pensez [ __ ] vous
faire [ __ ]
alors je préfère embrasser parce que se
faire embrasser ça va faire très mal
ouais je vous préfère les caresser ou
vous faire caresser ses dires de les
avoir à côté parce que je me dis c'est
l'expression non j'ai peur parce que
j'ai aussi jeudi
si je dis il me dire qu'il reste et j'ai
peur qu'elle me caresse oui c'est très
possible que c'est le genre de la maison
comprenez ma peur est là donc je préfère
me faire caresser d'accord sabrina est
ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer écouter
moi j'estime thierry que l'amour c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait avec quelqu'un
qu'on connaît depuis longtemps quelqu'un
qu'on qu'on aime se dire on avait il
faut qu'il ya besoin de vraiment d'une
rencontre de parler d'eux de se
connaître d'avoir quelque chose qui qui
je crois je pourrais viser le premier
saut
[Musique]
à vous préférez une femme qui baisent
bien mais qui était infidèle ou une
femme qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle franck si c'est pas la mienne je
préfère une femme qui baissent bien
qu'un fidèle si l'autre partenaire vous
propose une partie à trois vous préféré
que ce soit un homme ou une femme
préfère que ce soit une femme avec un
homme j'aurais trop peur de me faire
embrasser vous préféreriez que votre
femme vous quitte pour un homme pour une
femme pour une femme mais pas avec ma
maîtresse vous préféreriez que votre
femme couche avec un autre en pensant à
vous ou couche avec vous en pensant à un
autre oh ma femme ne pense pas thierry
mangin de couches pour manger
je plaisante sabrina les jantes
finalement la jeune sabrina couche en
pensant à vous ont pensé coucher avec
moi pour ça moi en amour vous êtes
partisan de tout se dire ou ne rien
savoir
sa voix au nom tout se dire c'est j'en
parle justement madore dans mon
spectacle leur chéri tu as fais l'amour
cet après midi génial raconte qu'est ce
qu'il t'a fait qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont
fait abadie non non non je ne les
couples libéré sais pas pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas couple libère du tout du tout
du temps venons enfin abouti je suis je
ne suis pas jaloux vous savez où elle
est là sincèrement tout de suite je m'en
fous un peu
alors
vous préféreriez faire l'amour à 1000
femmes toujours de la même façon ou à
une femme de mille façons différentes
je ne savais pas qu'il y avait mille
façons mais à mille femmes d'une façon
parce que chaque femme est différente
donc ce sera jamais pareil
ah oui d'accord pendant le sénat est à
70 ans c'est vrai vous préféreriez une
femme comprend sans la comprendre ou
qu'on comprend sans apprendre si je
pourrais faire baiser avec amélie
nothomb ou ophélie winter
je préférerais non je préfère une femme
que je ne prends pas que je comprends ah
oui c'est beau ça c'est pour ça que je
le dis sinon la vérité c'est l'autre
fruits
il faudra faire l'interview faux culs
vous préférez que la lumière soit et un
toit lui mais franck c'est à dire que ça
lui ben moi je fais l'amour tellement
longtemps que bien évidemment si elle
est allumée que c'est moi qui paye
ok interview focus je préfère la lumière
allumée pour pouvoir voir ma partenaire
bien entendu dans vos yeux dans les yeux
la dernière question est ce que vous
l'avez déjà fait dans l'eau oui ou en
vacances dans la méditerranée mais le
sable le sel dans la mer ça irrite
oui les femmes et donc
donc on n'a pas fait trop trop longtemps
quoi oui ce qui m'arrange et de guerre
selon vous est le client idéal pour une
interview
alerte aux roses
à lagord c'est des petits jeunes dakar
il ya un mouvement va s'élargir titre
bien alors les filles vous êtes prête
interview alerte rose
olivier est ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de faire
l'amour pour aimer c'est d'une
complexité de trucks intellectuelle moi
j'ai besoin de faire l'amour quand j'en
ai envie
ouais ce que vous avez besoin de boire
pour avoir soit d'avoir soif pour boire
voilà ce que vous préférez une femme qui
baissent bien mais qui est infidèle ou
une femme qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle
je crois que vraiment fond celle qui
baisent mal déjà elle sort donc le
premier anglais dont le seul crime est
bien fier les infidèles c'est pas un
drame
ouais t'es pas un drame vous préféreriez
que votre femme couche avec un autre en
pensant à vous vous couchez avec vous en
france en un autre je préfère qu'il y
ait à gérer mais non en fait je m'en
fous non mais vraiment
vous êtes en train de me poser des
questions si on a tout vu mais ces
questions vous êtes jamais posé vers mai
en amour vous êtes partisan de tout
savoir ou de rien se dire mais en plus
l'amour étant pas spécialement parlant
pour moi je vois pas pourquoi on saurait
tout on se dirait quelque chose vous
n'avez pas qu'on vous raconte ces gens
vient le mec était formidable et tout ça
c'est passé 18h30 à 21h 1 j'ai perdu les
clés de la voiture donne rien
certainement garde pas empêché d'agir
j'estime que ce que fait l'autre ne me
regarde pas vous voulez m'épouser
maintenant je pense qu'on serait
tranquille tous les deux vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec 1000
femmes toujours de la même façon
ou avec une femme de mille façons
différentes
c'est appétissant comme une pâtisserie
commandes quand on a 5 ans une femme
selon le vab toujours de la même façon
et où une femme de mille façons
différentes
incapable de choisir avec non non non je
de toutes les façons avec 1100 où je
vous sais pas je
moi je vous secouer tout d'un coup j'ai
autant parler lui disant vous mais
restent de loin fraude réapparaît je
sais pas alors si alors que c'est inepte
donc je ne sais pas je suis tout-à-fait
perplexe je réponds dans trois mois
d'accord becker d'accord bien d'avoir
gagné est ce que vous l'avez déjà fait
dans l'eau quand très très souvent de la
mer c'est quand même pratique c'est la
chambre d'hôtel la moins chère c'est le
sel ça vous irrite pas maintenant le sel
il se dépose après un préféré une femme
comprend sans la comprendre où une femme
qu'on comprend sans la prendre
c'est de prendre un gros pain dans la
gueule non pas du tout mais moi j'y
arrive pas vous m'excuserez je faire
thierry là je pars à comprendre ces
mécanismes là mais je sens qu'on
comprend déjà c'est héroïque dont le
reste est en réalité
si aulas si votre femme vous trompez
veut faire payer que ce soir avec un
homme ou avec une femme avec qui elles
veulent un son problème vous ai déjà dit
moi ouais
l'autre fait ce qu'il veut ça me regarde
pas je vais quand même pas être la péta
carton rouge
c'est une grande aide non ça me regarde
pas est-ce que se faire sucer c'est
tromper
puisque vous aimez beaucoup les femmes
c'est normal on veut faire une interview
alerte aux roses
[Applaudissements]
voilà talent via dany brillant est ce
que vous préférez draguer vous faire
draguer je crois je préfère draguer
quand même ouais ouais préféré embrasser
ou vous faire embrasser préfère
embrasser aussi caresser ou vous faire
caresser à je préfère me faire caresser
ça change préféré larguer ou faire
larguer à je préfère me faire larguer
parce que la largue et c'est très dur un
azur de rompre ouais cantonais du coeur
c'était très dur et on peut mettre même
deux ans à rompre
quel est l'endroit idéal pour faire
l'amour pour vous fiat 500 celle que
certains elle veut absolument vous de
dents dessus quel endroit vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour sur un
plateau de télé ne pourriez pas là alors
attention à ce que vous préférez une
femme qui baissent bien mais qui est
infidèle ou une femme qui héberge mal
mais qui est fidèle
c'est une vraie question bah je préfère
une femme cristina sion non je préfère
une femme qui est fidèle mais là mais de
même aimé mais je je je ferai en sorte
de l'initier d'accord pour que
finalement elles apprennent des mesures
de prendre une qui fait super bien foutu
moi je mange un message en prenant une
qui bosse bien et l'enferment à la
maison elle y était
alors est ce que vous pouvez faire rire
et qu'elle vous quitte pour un homme
pour une femme pour une femme il ya
moins de concurrence
ouais c'est duration et si tu peux tenir
la caméra ça fait du jura souvenir pour
y répondre
si vous voulez je réfléchis tiens par
exemple est-ce que vous préféreriez
faire l'amour à 1000 femmes toujours de
la même façon ou à une femme de mille
façons différentes
c'est une définition de l'enfer 1000
femmes toujours de la même façon ou une
femme de mille façons différentes
une femme de mille façons j'imagine à la
800e way
alors si vous deviez avoir que la moitié
d'une femme dany brillant vous prendriez
le haut ou le bas
lolo a est ce que dans ces s'est trompé
non denses et non embrasser s'est trompé
ça dépend où embrassé sur la bouche un
smack ou avec la langue grecque la
langue ça dépend pour la femme je crois
que c'est tromper mais pour moi non
[Applaudissements]
moi je vais dire que c'est tromper à
bien avant de mettre la langue s'est
trompé c'est tromper que dans ta tête tu
as vu qu'une envie c'est de grimper
dessus même si tu y as pas toucher ça
s'est déjà trompé
bien sûr alors que bien sûr alors que
grimper tce 100 sans s'en être pris par
la tête là s'est pas trompé ah qu'est ce
que tu racontes si elle embrasse capturé
ce qu'est ce qu'il se jugera tromper moi
je trouve pas ça grave d'embrasser je
trouve que on rencontre des gens dans
une soirée avec l'agent m'a dit avec la
langue qui dérape non non
et c'est pas et puis embrasser avec la
langue c'est pas juste comme ça penche
et tous les deux en avants sens toucher
c'est l'un contre l'autre c'est tout un
tas de balle et dernière question
la pierre est ce que se faire sucer
c'est tromper
ah bah oui bah ouais bah oui ah bon ah
là pour le coup c'est lorsque je
m'excuse mois là
questionnaire n y êtes prêtre la wii
c'est gentil cette récente interview
alerte aux roses
[Applaudissements]
à l'interview alerté rosa et 2 this you
3 et aliot près de vous alors que
generali est ce que vous préférez
draguer vous faire draguer je préfère
draguer préféré embrasser ou vous faire
embrasser embrasser ah oui vous êtes tu
ne viens j'aime bien tu vas adorer la
suite ce que vous pouvez faire et
caresser ou offert 15 et le faire car
est si large et vous faire larguer à
aucun disait ah oui non j'aime pas
impuissants face jeu axé il faut
répondre au rythme des annonces et c'est
vrai qu'elle est l'endroit idéal pour
vous pour faire l'amour l'endroit vous
êtes incapables de perdre mon jeu sur ce
nom ça me dérangerait pas c'est devant
les gens que j'aimerais pas aller sur
scène une scène vide
ce serait ça marrant c'est devant les
gens c'est pas possible
allons même si les gens ont payé mais
c'est sur le terrain par respect
l'examen alors attention et tapotage que
génèrent les armes vous préférez un mec
qui est une bonne affaire mais qui est
infidèle ou un mec est une mauvaise
affaire mais qui est fidèle
ton mari son amant je sais pas je ne
sais pas c'est vers la question là je
préfère encore une bonne affaire à fidel
je pense parce que parce que
j'ai souvent envie d'elle alors de toute
façon est ce que vous préférez qui vous
quitte pour un homme ou pour une femme
pas qu'ils me quitte déjà le cil vais
vous quittez un jeu c'est parce que
moins grave s'il était pour un mec moins
graves
ah non non non non plus grave plus
oui un peu plus grave un peu plus avec
quand même oui je supporte riez pas bah
oui parce que je vous dis je me dirai ce
que c est ce qu il était bien que moi
ouais generali est ce que vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec 1000 mec
toujours de la même façon dans un studio
ou avec un mec de mille façons
différentes
un mec de mille façons différentes si
vous deviez avoir que la moitié d'un
homme vous prendriez le haut ou le bas
voilà
c'était court mais serait infidèle à un
questionnaire est ce que dans ces s'est
trompé dans ce cas oui
kamano s qu'embrasser s'est trompé
[Musique]
c'est pas génial quand même un libyen et
c'est pas l'émission ci après non la
question michel rocard l'ami question
michel rocard oui c'est tromper le pire
est à venir
interview alerte aux roses
[Musique]
christophe dugarry est ce que vous
préférez draguer ou vous faire draguer
la ferme agri ça tombe bien ta commandé
depuis de son champion
est ce que vous préférez embrassez vous
faire embrasser les deux est-ce que vous
préférez caresser vous faire caresser
voilà va pas sans l'autre est-ce que
vous avez l'argus vous faire varier me
faire larguer faire larkin site le fera
quelle époque où christophe dugarry
l'endroit idéal pour faire l'amour quand
on aime y a pas d'endroit partout cela
partout ça va dans quel endroit
êtes-vous incapable de faire l'amour
l'anus ensuite
alors que service public dans un endroit
public où on voit directement ici ne
pourriez pas là par exemple la barre
transversale 70e
bien sûr que non non non mais devant
leur public et si on ferme tous les yeux
bien est ce que vous préférez une femme
qui baissent bien mais qui est infidèle
ou une femme qui baisent mal mais qui
est fidèle qui passe mal mais qui final
je les deux sur le plateau
est-ce que vous préféreriez christophe
dugarry que frédéric vous quitte pour un
homme ou pour une femme une femme avec
sa balle à l'ego est touché ah si
frédéric vous proposer de faire l'amour
à trois lui préféreriez que ce soit avec
un homme avec une femme zizou jeannie
longo s'est emparé canon et je peux
aller 3-1
jeannie longo
si vous aviez à voir que la moitié de
frédéric vous prendriez le haut ou le
bas le haut ce que le quart marc et
hubert hellman
en fait ça sert à est-ce que quand on
aime on peut tout faire
[Musique]
ouais je pense tous à la vaisselle les
courtes à est ce que est ce que vous
avez déjà christophe dugarry simuler
l'orgasme où je me souviens oui oui
magnéto c'est très beaux ralentis de des
guerriers qui voit pas comment on peut
aussi si on fait ça pour me faire
l'avocat thierry guignard team peut être
je peux leur faire s'il te plaît à a pu
le faire quatre fois tu es ce que vous
avez déjà prétexté christophe dugarry
une migraine pour refuser de faire
l'amour
[Musique]
une migraine en une fatigue oui à est-ce
que se regarder fixement comme ça
regardez moi michael se regardait
fixement comme ça pendant un dîner
pendant tout le dîner
est-ce que c'est tromper
un blocage d'une bien piètre non mais
pas trompé en banon n'est pas ça
commence ou tromper m'a trompé quand il
ya un acte pop un baiser s'est trompé
déjà ouais je pense même slalom
messieurs c'est trop et jacques et ses
droits
maintenant si tu as femmes embrasse aimé
jacquet christ
ne dites pas 99 au sujet du sexe les
hommes avec les femmes les hommes avec
les hommes les femmes avec les femmes
par deux ou en solitaire
pas de problème si chacun est consentant
donc vous méritez une interview alerte
aux roses
[Applaudissements]
alors marianne préférez vous draguer ou
vous faire draguer vous préféré
embrasser ou vous faire embrasser vous
préférez caresser ou vous faire caresser
voilà maintenant des cours vous préféré
larguer ou vous faire l'arrêt
1 la guerre quel est pour vous l'endroit
idéal pour faire l'amour dans une
voiture
[Musique]
tous les sports on avait une bonne paie
ont fait cette mamie ni dans la bêta
ai-je fait ses courses en belgique et
mariana dans quel endroit
etes-vous incapable de faire l'amour
dans un train ah oui oui mon première ça
n'a pas marché je mange pas pourtant
dans le train dix nommés tout un
avantage vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer offert la tapotage vous
préféreriez un homme qui baisent très
très bien mais qui est infidèle ou un
homme qui baisent très très mal mais qui
est fidèle
le premier a oui je pense encore à son
mari vous préféreriez qui vous quitte
pour un homme pour une femme
vous préféreriez qu'ils couchent avec
vous en pensant à une autre ou avec une
autre en pensant à vous
[Musique]
coucher avec moi c'est mieux même s'il
pense à une autre
oui on paie pour lui s'il pense à
dites-moi est-ce que faire l'amour par
téléphone s'est trompé non je crois pas
vous connaissez la question michel
rocard oui oui évidemment évidemment
même si c'est une petite [ __ ]
d
voilà jma c'est un grand moment c'est un
grand moment que j'attends depuis des
années michèle cotta
interview alerte aux roses
[Applaudissements]
je pars
voilà bonsoir talus au 2 et y sur trois
le bateau très bien j'ai le regarder
votre caméra et qui t'a valu mari
d'aller se coucher
bien cette charge des enfants cenap à
3,20
michel vous préférez draguer ou vous
faire draguer se faire draguer préféré
larguer ou faire larguer largué vous
préféré embrasser ou vous faire
embrasser s'en passer
caressez vous faire caresser
vraiment un égoïsme quoi se faire
caresser
quel est pour vous michel côté un début
idéal pour faire l'amour amis les bêtes
ouais j'ai des photos dans ton bureau
monsieur le lieu où il vous est
impossible de faire l'amour france 3
mais
verygames smart pipes en toile changé
parce qu'on dit que les gens qui ont des
grosses voitures ont les petites [ __ ] -
est-ce que vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour le faire l'amour qu'on
aimait à serrar ce adriana c'est pas du
tout ça c'est pas moi c'est cette
diversité qu'il ya un royal 66
est ce que vous préférez un homme qui
baisent bien mais qui est fidèle les
connais par coeur
un homme qui baisent bien mais qu'un
fidèle aux dames qui baisent malbec et
fidèle ça fait toujours s'arranger
tandis que l'infidèle ça s'arrange pas
oui donc vous comptez sur vous pour
l'arranger non à ses six coaccusés sur
la question posée elle est quand même à
la tête du paf à connaître
un capotage
est-ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec mille hommes toujours de la
même façon
ou avec un homme de mille façons
différentes agences et une trentaine de
toute une vie ça va moins réaliste but
est-ce que vous préféreriez que votre
mari à la pata pata couche avec une
autre en pensant à vous ou couché avec
vous en pensant à une autre ça voilà
c'est une question qui m'a beaucoup
interpellé tout là bas aussi un gène est
écouté tout rose avec moi on prend soin
quelqu'un d'autre va évidemment ça juste
pas d'accord
bon on décompte le nombre de personnes
ont alors fait ma pension à vous c'est
énorme c'est la moitié de la france et
ce soir ce soir c'est 80
sérieusement est-ce que vous préféreriez
que christian karembeu couche avec vous
en pensant à une autre ou couche avec
une autre on pensera à vous a oui couché
avec l'autre et on pense à moi c'est
l'inversé systématiquement opposé un
c'est de moi je suis réaliste
vous savez très pratique c'est vrai
michel michel aulas est ce que dans ces
s'est trompé quand la fille a les siens
dans le nord rappelons le principe d'un
plan d'eau pierre dumayet pierre dumayet
est-ce que embrasser s'est trompé non
est-ce que vous connaissiez michel
rocard jusque rennais s'est trompé
personne avec lui
et
michèle cotta mesdames messieurs et oui
vous n'y couperez pas patricia kaas
interview à verte rose
[Applaudissements]
dagnaud de eti sur trois attention
patricia kaas est ce que vous préférez
draguer ou vous faire draguer ben j'ai
pas le choix alors draghi largué vous
faire larguer marquer voilà bon connais
un petit peu là avance en brasse et vous
faire en boîte cette époque et voilà
quand c'est jeremy iron vous l'embrassez
canon non c'est non c'est bien ces
succès les deux on peut pas l'obliger
quel est le lieu idéal pour faire
l'amour
je peux pas répondre parce que j'ai pas
encore fait l'amour dans tous les ans
dans possible ça peut déranger
vous avez essayé quoi par exemple au bas
des trucs classiques la voiture le lait
oui enfin la voiture les italiens se la
machine à laver
c'est vrai je suis libre on ne saura
jamais
parce qu'ils sont feignants c'est la fin
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour
pourrait mais je préférerais mais pour
faire l'amour
sinon ça peut pas faire l'amour sans
saper le baiser d'accord c'est la bonne
réponse
préférez un mec qui bosse bien mais
qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui bosse mâles
métier fidèles je préfère savoir qu'il
est fidèle mais
il peut être infidèle et bien de faire
l'amour oui bon allez on va faire ça
peut faire varier être caressé par
quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu par
quelqu'un qui vous aime
[Musique]
battu mais gentiment dakar vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec 1000 mec
toujours de la même façon
ou avec un mec de mille façons
différentes folle expérience de la vie
un mec même de mille façons différentes
ça ça dépend de ton passé si site a
connu des mecs avant alors je veux bien
même d'accord de façon différente si
t'as pas assez d'expérience je préfère
mille mais de façon à ce que de toute
façon chacun sera différent oui si vous
ne deviez avoir que une moitié de lui
vous préféreriez que ce soit le haut ou
le bas nous
bah oui parce que le bas il ya des
manières différentes
vous connaissez michel rocard
personnellement non
vous connaissez la question michel
rocard ne connaissez pas la question
michel rocard est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper sa dépense reçu
allo ouais soit 10 c père est un [ __ ]
monsieur par tous téo je viens pas
d'accord je viens ce que j'ai pas de
problème mais bien si ta femme vient
péri dommage
ah oui
je suis
faye est évidemment j'allais jallet fait
de laisser venir au casse-pipe tout seul
mais bon il s'en sort pas trop mal tout
les gens sont marais à ça a l'air sympa
non ah ouais tu vois je pense que
nourriture de vivre non mais c'est une
connerie le bouquet n'existe pas c'est
très sympa non mais je vous le conseille
pour une seule raison c'est que ça entre
du pognon la maison ça c'est déjà une
raisonnable n'était pas pour celle-là
c'est que par pas fini de le lire et que
tu vois une mouche passé dans ta chambre
un truc comme ça tu dis c'est peut-être
quelqu'un que je connais qui en train de
mater en train de regarder ce que je
fais dans mon livre c'est un peu dommage
que tu étais là parce qu'il y avait un
truc entre mélanie et guillaume là je
peux repartir si tu veux c'est ce que je
vais vous faire un but que je vous ai
tous les deux une interview alerte aux
roses
terry est ce que tu as besoin d'aimer
pour faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour
pour aimer moi je dirais les deux ça
dépend des jours à l'aller on est bien
un
et toi moi ça dépend de la fille c'est
quoi ta première pensée péri quand tu te
trouve en face d'un mec séduisant je me
demande si dit la vérité la vérité c'est
est ce que je peux lui plairait ce que
ça peut aller plus loin est ce que je
sais pas non franchement j'ai pas que tu
vois et même séduisant c'est ça chaque
fois que je te vois tu chantes pas comme
des trucs qui te pousse
menora mae m c'est quoi le lieu idéal
pour une étreinte pourquoi ce que les
italiens sur la machine à laver vous
savez ça mais sur les forages
ouais tu resteras sauvage ouais c'est
quoi mais pas l'intérieur un esprit très
rock et l'atr guillaume le lieu idéal
pour une étreinte pour toi juste au pied
du lit avant de monter avant de voir ce
qui m'est chère à votre question c'est
bon guillaume est ce que tu préfères une
femme qui pèse bien mais qui est
infidèle ou une femme qui baisent malbec
et fidèle femme qui laisse bien fidèles
à m oui est ce que tu préfères draguer
ou de faire draguer ça dépend qui j'ai
en face de moi mais tu devras que des
fois ouais oui je les draguer je
préférerais qu'elle te quitte pour une
femme pour un homme pour un homme
chossat plus marrant ah ouais moi aussi
je veux faire et on quitte pour un homme
ouais c'est vrai est ce que tu préfères
être caressé par quelqu'un qui très puiu
battu par quelqu'un qui t'aiment ans
battu par quelqu'un qui m'aime pas
est ce que tu préfères que perry couche
avec un autre en pensant à toi au
coucher avec toi on pense en a un autre
qui est une couche avec moi en pensant à
un autre moi c'est pas mal ça qu'elle
couche avec toi moi oui même si jamais
ça résultat quinté 1re série
ouais tu vois je préfère me coucher avec
toi en pensant à une autre qui couche
avec une autre pensons à toi qui couche
avec moi en pensant à moi ah c'est pas
possible c'est trop tard autant est ce
que bon j'avais 20 ans vous êtes
ensemble
l'excusé encore un fantasme inavouables
et non réalisés inavoués non j'ai tout
fait on s'est tous dit surtout est ce
que l'amour est compatible avec le
mariage père a péri pardon à wind on
assiste ici complètement la page la
preuve la preuve vivante depuis 20 ans
je les adore j'espère que les mariés de
la donne depuis 20 ans vous êtes pas
trompés jamais trompé n'ont trompé non
parce que celui-ci s'est trompé ça
dépend ce que tu sais répond ce que tu
suces perry est ce que sucer c'est
tromper si tu mens oui pour moi tromper
c'est mentir
tu ressembles un oui c'est vrai se
dissout son nom si tu ne ment pas t'as
pas trompé donc voilà après donc su
s'est pas trompé son homélie
donc tu vas j'avais bien bossé jaloux et
je cite et de quoi
tu penses quand on avoue finalement non
pas quand on avoue quand on dit oui
c'est pas à vous et à vous et ça
déflation avoué de métier co2 mais oui
non mais avouez c'est à dire que tu as
menti et que tu te leurs proches et
qu'ensuite tu te dis tiens je vais
l'avouer je vais le dire là c'est pas du
tout ça donc simuler s'est trompé ouais
bah oui je suis assis l'arrivée s'est
trompé on apprend des trucs c'est le
service public à la menace est plus
obligé d'apprendre des choses un petit
peu gens est-ce que vous éteignez use
allumer la lumière quand vous baisez
chez vous non franchement non il n'y a
pas de règle je ne suis pas ta
atteindrait du toi tu non non j'ai la
drague les basques depuis 82 n'y a pas
de règle
c'est quoi la zone la plus érogène chez
toi perry pas éclater
merci il l'a dit pour moi
kerry avec quelles personnes ici
présentes tu aimerais avoir une aventure
soit honnête imagine conçoit dans un
monde idéal où ça pose pas de problème
on a connu ça dans les années 70 mais
bon maintenant c'est fini
un truc à plusieurs mais pas en dessous
moi parce qu'il fait 130 kg alors c'est
guillaume et odette avec qui tu voudrais
avoir une aventure là à moi moi ma
voisine il est génial c'est de la merde
et il te la leffe attache pas miss
france
est ce que tu préfères une femme belle
école ou une femme moche et intelligente
vous l'avez téléphone
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu préfères une femme
comprend sans la comprendre qu'on
comprend sans la france
on comprend sans la prendre ah ouais
j'ai pas compris des capable de ça tu
vois qu'on comprend sans la prendre je
préfère une femme qu'on comprend et
comprend pas si tu pouvais posséder que
la moitié de perry tu prendrais le bas
ou le haut comme dans le bas le bas
pourquoi là bas parce qu'il ya et tu
vois si vous voulez prendre que la
moitié de guillaume tu pourrais le bas
ou le haut non moi je prends l'eau parce
que tout est dans la tête de tous les
journaux mais si justement à tout est
dans la tête parce que même si on va
parler de fantasmes sexualité etc
c'est aussi dans la tête des gens bien
du coteau bout du crew que ceux
rencontrés par le ou vers le haut voilà
merci merci dernière question vous
baiser avant le restaurant où après le
restaurant au restaurant talotti ça peut
être au restaurant oui plus souvent
après pourrai manger plus souvent après
qu'avant chaque fois que ces deux
restaurants ont enrichi dans tous les
soirs
[Musique]
cb